zweite Chance für die Stadt Warstein im
Sauerland lange war sich der Stadtrat
einig kein Windpark im nahegelegenen
Wald doch heute ist die Ausgangslage
völlig neu das Sauerland leidet nicht
nur unter dem Klimawandel sondern auch
unter der Energiekrise
schweren und damit auch bedeutungsvollen
Sitzung begrüßen um diesen Wald geht es
500 Hektar inzwischen Karl geräumt weil
Orkane heiße Sommer und der Borkenkäfer
80% aller Fichten im Sauerland
vernichtet haben die Waldbauern Wangen
um ihre wirtschaftliche Existenz
es ist für uns nach wie vor eine
riesenkatastrophe denn uns fallen
dadurch dass der Wald verschwunden ist
über 30 bis 40 Jahre jegliche Einnahmen
aus
das hoffen wir natürlich durch
Windkraftprojekte
egalisieren zu können seit mehr als zehn
Jahren kämpfen die Waldbauern um die
Baugenehmigung für ihre Windräder bisher
vergeblich wegen zweier Brutplätze des
schwarzstorches mussten drei der 15
geplanten Windräder gestrichen werden
das aber ist selbst unter Naturschützern
umstritten denn in weggerissenen Wäldern
brüten Schwarzstörche gar nicht betonte
der Bund schon voriges Jahr
artenschutz ist ein wichtiger Belang
auch bei der Planung von
Windenergieanlagen aber viele
Bürgerinitiativen instrumentalisieren in
Artenschutz missbrauchen den
Schwarzstorch um solche Planungen zu
verhindern tausende Einsprüche gegen den
geplanten Windpark inmitten der
Touristenregion Arnsberger Wald eine
Bürgerinitiative verfasste 2018 diesen
gemeinsamen Aufruf aus Sorge das
Landschaftsbild werde durch Windräder
verunstaltet mit Unterzeichner der
Sauerländer Friedrich Merz heute
Oppositionschef im Bundestag ein halbes
Jahr nach Putins Überfall auf die
Ukraine präsentiert sich mehr als an
anderer Stelle für Windkraft besucht den
Windpark Marsberg im Sauerland ich
befürworte seit jeher konzentrierte
Standorte dies ist einer schön ist das
nicht im ästhetischen Sinne aber es ist
notwendig für die Energieerzeugung in
unserem Land mit Friedrich Merz hätten
wir gern darüber geredet er aber nicht
mit uns zwei schriftliche Anfragen ließ
er unbeantwortet auch Katharina Kramer
will nicht mit uns reden sie hatte
damals ebenfalls gegen den Windpark
unterschrieben sie ist Besitzerin der
Warsteiner Brauerei und die braucht eben
auch bezahlbaren Strom inzwischen hat
sie ihre Meinung geändert schriftlich
teilt sie uns mit Zitat
meine Unterschrift 2018 resultierte aus
meiner Sorge heraus dass diese
touristisch genutzte Gegend nicht ohne
Augenmaß optisch verändert werden sollte
aber seit der Energiekrise ist die
Notwendigkeit für den Ausbau aller
erneuerbaren Energieformen enorm
gestiegen
Wald ist ohne Bäume touristisch ziemlich
wertlos also ein neues Geschäftsmodell
vielleicht von Lichtenau lernen heute
Energie statt früher war hier wenig
heute ist der Strom hauptsächlich aus
Windkraft zehnmal so viel wie die Stadt
selbst verbraucht
westfalenwind sitzt hier die Firma die
den Windpark in den Resten des
Arnsberger Waldes betreiben will
das Thema erneuerbare Energien wird
jetzt durch den Ukraine Krieg deutlich
dringender und ernster genommen und wir
erleben dass viele Gemeinden viele
Bürger und auch Industriebetriebe sagen
wir brauchen euren Strom und die
Einstellung hat sich dadurch massiv
verändert sicher auch dadurch dass voll
verspargelte Kommunen mehr Steuern
einnehmen 90% der Gewerbesteuer aus
regenerativer Energie muss dort bleiben
wo die Rotoren stehen in Lichtenau
profitiert jeder einzelne Bürger
zusätzlich die Bürger sind als
Miteigentümer an den Projekten beteiligt
wir haben hier eine Stiftung gegründet
die jährlich 200.000 € an die Vereine
ausschütten kann und wir haben hier
bürgerstromtarife das heißt die
Haushalte bekommen hier günstigen
Haushaltsstrom der günstiger ist als
anderswo das ganze hat sogar hohen
Akzeptanz geführt
das führt dazu dass die Bürger hier mit
hoher Mehrheit zustimmen und nichts
dagegen haben dass sie ihre Landschaft
hier erheblich verändert hat
günstiger grüner Strom aus regionaler
Erzeugung darauf hofft auch der
Chip-Hersteller Infineon in Warstein er
braucht viel Strom für seine Produktion
von Halbleitern die am Ende wieder auch
in Windräder eingebaut werden
Infineon rechnet damit den Strom aus dem
Arnsberger Wald zu kaufen und Westfalen
sind bietet Sonderkonditionen
können Sie Zahlen nennen also konkrete
Zahlen nicht aber wir können ungefähr
sagen dass wir als wir die die ersten
Informationsgespräche mit Westfalen Wind
hatten und ein Preis genannt wurde lag
dieser Preis zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
etwa auf dem Niveau den wir auch für den
Netzstrom bezahlt haben mittlerweile
sind diese Strompreise nahezu doppelt so
hoch südlich von Warstein der Kreissägen
Wittgenstein auch hier ist von den
Fichtenbeständen aufgrund des
Klimawandels nicht mehr viel übrig auch
hier müssen die Waldbesitzer umdenken
in der Nähe von Bad Berleburg soll auf
diesen Bergrücken Deutschlands größter
Windpark Neubau mit 59 Windrädern
entstehen
Investor ist Prinz Gustav zu sein
Wittgenstein Berleburg gemeinsam mit
westfalenwind der Schlossherr will über
das Meer als 350 Millionen Euro schwere
Investment jetzt in der frühen
Planungsphase noch nicht öffentlich
sprechen der Bürgermeister von Bad
Berleburg rechnet aber nicht mit
Bürgerprotesten wie sie früher gab jetzt
in diesem Krisenzeiten sei die Akzeptanz
für grüne Energie deutlich gestiegen
der schreckliche Angriffskrieg von Putin
hat schon zu einem Bewusstseinswandel
geführt die sogenannte Zeitenwende macht
deutlich dass es hier eine andere
Haltung gibt und wenn sie in die
Landschaft reinschauen wird es auch
sichtbar denn der Wald ist zum Großteil
eben nicht mehr vorhanden und das ist
hier jetzt die Möglichkeit gibt
entsprechend Windkraftanlagen
aufzustellen aber auch natürlich das
ganze über Photovoltaikanlagen über
andere erneuerbare Formen der Energie zu
ergänzen diese Notwendigkeit ist glaube
ich allen bewusst zurück in die
Ratssitzung in Warstein die
Fernsehkamera muss draußen bleiben kurz
vor der Abstimmung die Meinungen immer
noch gespalten
Windräder sind grundsätzlich wichtig für
unser Klima bin ich auch nicht dagegen
aber nicht im Arnsberger Wald Windräder
ja aber nicht vor meiner Haustür es hat
mit meiner Haustür nichts zu tun ich
finde Windräder völlig in Ordnung ich
kann mir die auch gerne angucken also es
gibt genügend aber nicht in dem Wald
mein Stand ist dass die Baugenehmigung
bereits 2008 eingereicht wurden und mit
diesem Tempo können wir die klimawände
nicht schaffen wir brauchen Tempo für
die Erneuerbaren wir brauchen Rückenwind
für die Windenergie und das geht nur mit
schnellen Verfahren
der Rat der Stadt Warstein stimmt
schließlich mit knapper Mehrheit für den
Windpark auch weil der Bürgermeister
seine Meinung geändert hat ich habe
gegen Windkraft in Naturpark Arnsberger
Wald massiv gekämpft
und das sind jetzt acht Jahre und dann
kam der 24 Februar diesen Jahres der
imperiale Überfall Russlands auf die
Ukraine und wir stellten das Undenkbare
fest die Energieversorgung einer
Industrienation ist gefährdet und das
hat mich ins Grübeln gebracht wir wollen
hier auch im Sauerland unseren Beitrag
zur Energieversorgung des Landes auf
ökologischer Basis Leiste nach der
Ratsentscheidung haben die Warsteiner
Waldbauern jetzt Politik und Verwaltung
auf ihrer Seite so wie inzwischen auch
große Teile der Bevölkerung die
Akzeptanz hat sich schon dahin gehen
geändert dass sich ein Umdenken bereit
macht und auch eine wie immer mehr eine
Zustimmung erfahren oder auch gefragt
werden wann geht es endlich los
für ein Umdenken in Warstein brauchte es
zwei Katastrophen Klimawandel und
Ukraine Krieg